As we discussed in the introductory lesson,
the first step when creating a data model is to plan, meaning,
that we need to understand the underlying requirements and the available data sources.
What do we need to create the desired reports and where can we access this data?
Does it even exist somewhere in the first place?
There are a lot of different ways that data can be organized successfully,
but it's very important that you have a good sense of
what you're building before you start to try to build it.
Going back to the plumber analogy,
it won't do to start building out a bathroom only to find out that
the sink is planned out where the client requires a bidet.
So in a work environment,
this would be the fact-gathering stage where we'd be meeting with colleagues to
talk through the reporting needs and requirements usually with a big whiteboard nearby.
Then with the team's needs in mind,
we sketch out how the data available might fit together to meet this need.
This sketching itself is a key skill to have when preparing and modeling data,
not the actual drawing itself.
You don't need to be an artist to do this and your sketches don't need to look pretty.
Mine certainly do not.
The key goal here is simply to think through
the data pipeline first before you jump into building something.
This is meant to help you conceptualize how the data will look and connect,
including identifying the columns you do or don't need from your different sources.
The way I draw a table for example tends to just look like this,
with a few column headers at the top and squiggles to represent the data.